some exciting news from two-time Oscar
winner Hillary Swank the 48 year old
star of Million Dollar Baby announced
the birth of her twins yes she wrote on
Instagram yesterday it wasn't easy but
boy and girl was it worth it the new mom
of two shares twins with her husband of
four years Phillip Schneider smike
announced her pregnancy last fall when
she told the TV show Extra why she
waited until she was 48 to have children
in her words quote I was having a career
and not having the right relationship
until four years ago and then all the
elements needed to come together and be
right when Swank reveals she was having
twins she called it her double feature
women everywhere got lots of questions
how did you do it how did it work yeah I
mean what did you do we were Brianna my
producer were researching I mean happy
for her very happy yeah it's happening
more and more I mean the the the birth
rate among women in their late 40s has
gone through the roofs in the last 10
years
congratulations to them A Whole New
World